[Music]  it's been seven months since Brad Pitt  and Angelina Jolie's bitter breakup and  visitation battle started  but it appears things may be looking up  for Brad when it comes to spending time  with his six kids the source close to  Brad's inner circle confirms he recently  had his first overnight visit with all  of his children at his home and adds  that the children's nannies were also  there as was recommended by the family  therapist the source points out Angelina  employs the nannies because quote  Angelina is the one with sole physical  custody of the children so of course she  has more nannies brad has no need to  have his own nannies right now and we  will get you this time and and hopefully  be a stronger family for it  former couple remains focused on family  despite rumours our source tells us  neither Angie nor Brad have been dating  it's all about the kids